- [Mark] All right, Adam.
Adam, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Los Angeles, California,
born and raised.
Spent some of my younger
years in Northern California
in Sonoma County.
When my birth parents split up,
then end up moving back to Los Angeles
and spent most of my time
growing up here in LA.
- [Mark] And you, tell
me about your childhood,
you had both parents?
- Well, my father stayed
in Northern California
and my mother and I
moved with my stepfather,
who is George DiCaprio.
My mother met George in San Francisco.
She was in a guerrilla
theater dance troupe
called Freestore that was led
by a man named Vito Paulekas
who, at one point in the late '60s,
was part of the love-in movement
and the drop-in, get high,
the whole '60s thing,
in Laurel Canyon with
The Mothers of Invention
and Frank Zappa.
- [Mark] Right.
- And they started the first
love-ins in Griffith Park,
and this guy Vito was
a sculpting instructor
at Barnsdall Park, actually, in Hollywood,
and in the late '60s, early
'70s, a lot of the hippies
from that movement moved
to Northern California
to Sonoma County.
Vito was one of them and he started
this sort of vaudevillian
theater dance troupe
that my mom was a part of,
and they did these really elaborate acts
that were costumed and
choreographed and everything,
and they would perform
on stage in Berkeley
and San Francisco and Union
Square and these public places,
and they were sort of
like political satire,
anti-establishment, like
skits and stuff like that.
There was one actually where
my mom assassinated Santa Claus
(chuckles) in fishnet
stockings and high heels.
- [Mark] Fun.
- And it was pretty cool, and
so it was called Freestore.
The Freestore was actually
a shack that Vito had built
in this little town in
Sonoma County called Cotati
where it was like a Goodwill.
It was like a homemade Goodwill,
so it had a sign on the top
that said Freestore and people
would go and drop shit off
and you could go and pick things up,
clothes and toys and stuff like that.
So, anyway, my mom was a
part of this dance troupe.
She met George, they hit it off.
We moved back to Los Angeles,
and shortly thereafter,
after coming back to LA,
I started to work on television.
I got work on TV commercials.
There was a girl in my first grade class
whose mom was a manager, and
she met my mom at a PTA meeting
and told my mom that I was
gregarious and outspoken
and articulate for my age,
and that I would do good
to go see this agent.
- [Mark] As an actor.
- Yeah, in Sunset Plaza,
this agent, Iris Burton,
to go see her and see
if she would sign me,
go out on auditions, and she did,
she signed me immediately
and I started going out
on additions and making good money.
So we grew up in Los
Feliz, right in Los Feliz,
east of Hollywood, in a little house,
in a little white Craftsman house,
and Leo lived with his mom one block over,
kind of our houses were separated.
The backyards were separated
by a dirt lot, this vacant lot.
All they did in the winters
was they sold Christmas trees there.
- [Mark] So your stepbrother is Leonardo.
- Is Leonardo di Caprio, yeah.
- [Mark] Got it, okay.
- Yeah, yeah, so when I was four,
that's about four, between four and five,
that's when we moved back to
LA, and my mom met his dad,
and they've been married ever since.
Never had any more kids,
never had any other siblings
or anything besides he and I.
Then my dad remarried and he
lived in Northern California
and I would spend summers,
I would, summer vacations,
Christmas vacations, I would leave LA.
I'd get out of LA, I'd go
to Northern California,
I'd spend with my dad, so
I had this really magical,
fairytale-like time in
my summer vacations,
hanging out in Sonoma County.
- [Mark] Yeah, Sonoma's beautiful.
- In the 80s, with BMX bikes
and smoking really good pot
and hanging out, being a teenager,
swimming in the rushing river
and the creeks and stuff
when the water was still clean,
when you didn't get ear
infections and stuff
swimming in swimming holes
and you could actually swim in rivers
and the creeks and stuff when I was a kid,
and yeah, it was a really special time.
Then my grandmother
moved, my dad lived in LA.
See, everybody grew up
in LA and then some moved
out to Northern California.
My grandmother on my father's
side lived in Mendocino,
the town of Mendocino,
and that was beautiful.
I'd spend Christmases up there.
Every Christmas, we'd go
to the town of Mendocino,
and my grandmother lived
in this 135-year-old Victorian house,
this real old fucking cool
house up there on the headlands
in this historic town
in Northern California,
so, those were my Christmases.
- [Mark] So, it sounds
like a great childhood.
- Yeah, it was cool
growing up, so it was both.
I got the dichotomy of
living in Los Angeles
and experiencing that.
I kind of burned out on
acting when I was young.
It was a lot, it was get out
of school and go on auditions,
and that was every day, so,
as a teenager, 15, I remember,
around 14, 15, I started burning out
and I got into skateboarding
and I kind of went to
that instead, and Leo,
my little brother, he saw me doing that,
saw me making money.
We didn't spend any of the money.
This is a little caveat is
all of the money that I made
when I was acting, since
we were on food stamps
and welfare growing up, all
of that money got put away
as a ward of the court and
the judge oversaw the account,
so any money was gonna be done
anything with that account,
a judge had to oversee
it and have a court order
to do anything with that money.
So when I was 18, I got
handed all of the money
that I made acting.
It was like $186,000, something like that.
I had all that money when I was 18.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- I'm 48 now, so, there's a big gap there.
So, 18, so got handed that money.
Actually partied, had a really good time
with some of the money for a little bit
then tried to go to college,
it didn't really work out,
joined the army.
Went off to the army for four years.
Did the army for four years, did two tours
in the first Gulf War.
Desert Shield, Desert Storm,
stationed at Abu Dhabi Air
Force Base in Saudi Arabia.
So did two tours in the first Gulf War,
did four years at Fort Benning, Georgia,
and got out of the army, went to college,
went to Pasadena City
College for two years,
and then transferred to USC,
and went there for two years.
Got my Bachelor of Arts at USC.
And then for a little
while, for some time,
worked for my brother.
Right around this time
was when Titanic came out.
So I actually started a
company that had to do with,
it's called Fan Effects, and
we were gonna do fan sections
of websites and official merchandising
and everything like that for celebrities,
and I started that company
based on his success in Titanic.
Company actually did really well.
We made a million
dollars in the first year
and I ended up just
selling off the company
and taking an $80,000 severance pay,
something like that,
so, that was in the 90s.
In the 90s, I started
partying a lot in Hollywood,
clubs and stuff in Hollywood,
doing a lot of drugs and stuff,
so, that's kind of progressed
as the years have gone by.
- [Mark] Yeah.
When did drugs really get
into the picture for you?
- Well, they were always in the picture
but it was always just
sort of pot growing up.
It was always pot, and I'd
say I guess in the 90s,
after '95, '96, around those years,
just hanging out more in clubs
or in Hollywood drinking,
doing coke and stuff like
that, staying up all night,
but really, no serious, regular addictions
or anything like that.
More sort of just partying
and binge drinking
and stuff like that.
Opiates and real addiction
and stuff like that,
for me, really took over more,
I'd say in the last 10 years,
something like that,
yeah, since 2008, 2009,
somewhere around there.
- [Mark] And was it--
- Started kinda late.
- [Mark] Was, had you been
playing around with heroin
before that or is it?
- Yeah, I had used socially.
I'd been able to use
casually here and there.
I used cocaine, ecstasy, drank, of course,
and pot, there's always pot,
and a little bit of meth.
There was really good,
called it glass back then,
it was glass, but never
really had one drug
that really got me, that
I spent every day going
and getting money and buying and scoring
like I am now with
heroin, or fentanyl now,
but, now it's switched over to fentanyl.
Now it's not heroin anymore.
Now we all do fentanyl now,
which is strange, but...
- [Mark] You have to be
careful with that, right?
- Yeah, yeah, you do.
For the most part, yeah,
you have to be careful,
so, regulate how much we use.
These small amounts and stuff,
but you still have to be careful.
I always have Narcan on hand, so.
- [Mark] Have you OD'd?
- I OD'd one time, yeah.
Once I OD'd.
I had been in jail for
about eight or nine days.
This was when I was still
doing heroin, and I did a shot,
I did a one, a 1., so .10 amount
of black heroin in a shot,
and I went out, I planked out,
and I fell down and I
seized up a little bit,
hit my head kinda on the
bathroom counter on the way down,
and they gave me one dose of Narcan,
and that one does of
Narcan brought me back.
10 minutes later, I was fine, I was awake
and I felt fine because if
your system is cleaned out
and you're truly ODing
and you get Narcanned,
you don't go into this
horrible forced withdrawal.
If you have a bunch of dope in your system
and you get Narcanned, you go
into this horrible withdrawal,
but I didn't get that.
- [Mark] And have you been clean?
- I've been working on getting clean.
I've been back and forth,
back and forth with it
for some time now, so struggling with it.
I want to get back into the
good graces of my family,
and Charity, my wife and I
have a 12-year-old daughter together,
who's living now with my mom,
and I want to have her back in my life,
so I've been working, trying to get,
aside from the place that
we have, we rent a room
but I'm trying to get
my own house going on,
going through that whole process,
through housing and social
security and all that,
and getting those services set up.
I am service rated disabled
through the VA also.
I get disability through the VA
and I'm working on getting SSI.
So I already have benefits through VA
and I'm getting that
monthly currently already,
so, I'm well on my way
to getting things set up
and getting my ducks in order.
It's taken some time, but...
- [Mark] What does fentanyl do for you?
- It's similar to heroin.
I mean, it basically replaced
the heroin addiction.
We started doing heroin that
had a lot of fentanyl in it.
- [Mark] Is it basically the same?
- They sort, pretty much the same,
the same high, the same
kind of get down, the same,
you have to keep it in your
system or you're gonna get sick.
You have to stay ahead of the addiction,
and basically just a way to check out,
basically a way to kinda just
stay numb for the most part.
- [Mark] I mean, do you,
I mean, you don't sound
like you have some childhood events
that you're trying to numb out.
- No, not particularly, no.
More just sort of the pain of, I mean,
I do have the separation from my family,
and I don't really have
that connection and that,
I don't really have that
closeness with my family,
any of my family members,
except for my father.
He's all the way at, my
father's in Hawaii now,
my blood father, but yeah,
they sort of have distanced me
and black sheeped and
pariahed me, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Marginalized me.
- [Mark] You're a drug addict.
- As it were, so yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] You're a dreaded drug addict.
- Yeah, the family drug
addict, so, there's always one.
That's me.
- [Mark] Yeah, so...
- I don't mean to
trivialize it or anything.
It's sad, it is what it is.
It's my choice, I take
responsibility for it,
and I don't really point
the finger, like you said,
at any childhood event or
any abuse or molestation
or anything like that, I can't really,
I mean, for the most part, our
parents provided for us well.
Even though we were on
food stamps and welfare,
they still took us to the
movies and amusement parks
and family outings on weekends
and then hiking in the hills
and lots of stuff.
Tried to, cultured us, the
parades and different events
and social events and
different cultural events
around the city growing up.
Museums and, there's a
lot to experience in LA.
There used to be this big
thing called the Street Scene
in Downtown LA.
It was really cool.
It was, streets were all blocked off,
there were concerts and stuff,
and that was all the way up till the 80s.
- [Mark] Is there anything that,
like having a wildly successful brother?
- That definitely, at one
point, when I stopped working
for the Fan Effects, the company
that I made out of college,
when I kind of went off
and did my own thing,
there was a little bit of a turning away,
a little bit of a pity
party sort of a thing.
- It's kind of like having
a wildly successful father.
- Right, and then you
get your own way and go,
screw this, I don't need this.
It's the ultimate, fuck
you, I don't need this,
you know what I mean?
I don't want to be a part of
this and then walking away,
and then hoping that somebody comes
and invites you anyway to the premiere.
I have, all the way up until recently,
I was doing pretty well.
I was working in television production.
I'm actually Local 44
in the Carpenters' Union
for TV commercials, music
videos, so I work on sets.
I'm a set decorator and a carpenter
and a builder and a prop guy.
I do all that stuff, and I've
been doing that since 2002.
That's when I worked on my first video.
We worked on 50 Cent's
first video, Wanksta.
Filmed it right over here
on 8th and Normandie,
(scoffs) and that's how I kind of broke
into that whole industry
was working on low-budget
hip hop videos at first.
Guys that were just
getting into the industry,
and then, actually, as 50 Cent took off,
as his career took off,
so did a bunch of us
who were working in that
business at the time.
We were able to kind of
piggyback off of his success
and move up in that world,
which was kind of cool.
So I've done that for quite some time
and I could go back to that
and my family would take
me back in probably,
and probably have a trust
fund and all of that,
but I just have to stay clean.
The main thing is they just,
they want me to be clean.
My mom kinda got wind that
I was hooked on heroin
and then I was kind of
just spinning my wheels
and not really moving forward
and she made a couple of
phone calls and CPS came.
She was able to get custody of
our daughter, which is okay.
She's taken good care of,
my parents live right over,
not far from us in Silver
Lake, and they got a big house
with the pool and a screening room,
so she's able to have friends
over and have movie night
and pool parties and
everything, so, she's--
- [Mark] And how old's your daughter?
- She's 12 years old now.
- [Mark] 12, and does she know you--
- She lived with us all the way up
until four or five years ago,
until my mom got custody.
- [Mark] Does she know that
you guys are down here?
- She doesn't know we're downtown,
she doesn't know specifically.
We don't talk specifically all the time.
Her mother has more
contact with her than I do.
- [Mark] Then you, but
you visit her often?
- So, no, we've stopped doing visitation.
We're at the point now where,
it's been a long, hard battle.
We've burned through 15,
close to $20,000 in attorneys
that haven't been able to do anything.
They just kind of take your money.
$20,000, they just kind of laugh at that.
That's just kind of like an
ante up kind of an amount,
and so we've gone through
hell with court battles
and custody courts and stuff like that,
and we're still working on it
but we're kind of defeated right now.
We've kind of been, we feel a
little bit conspired against
by the system and by the, by
what seems to be some type
of corruption within the
system and the ability
of our parents to manipulate
the powers that be
to get what they want, basically.
So, it's just kind of
defeating and deflating
and energy-draining, to say the least, so.
- [Mark] Yeah, it must be.
But so sometimes you're
staying here on Skid Row.
- Yeah, yeah, sometimes, yeah,
sometimes for days at a time,
we'll be down here.
We do have a place in
Silver Lake where we go,
where we stay sometimes,
too, but just because of lack
of having enough drugs or whatever,
sometimes we'll just stay downtown.
- [Mark] And you're staying in a tent or?
- I have stayed in tents.
We do have various places
where we stay indoors.
We have rented rooms in different places
and have friends that have SROs
and when it gets really cold,
you kind of try to figure
out where to go indoors.
- [Mark] I mean, do you have
still have money saved or?
- No, but I do get monthly.
I get money every month from
the VA for my disability still,
so I do have income.
- [Mark] Got it.
- So I am able, once a month,
I do get a chunk of money,
and I'm able to hold onto that
for some time, through the month.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Sometimes we get hotel rooms,
but nothing really steady.
It's just kind of sporadic.
We just kind of take it
by, take it day by day.
Last night, we stayed in a
staircase, in a warm staircase
in this building, this loft
building we know the code for.
We went in and it was
carpeted and nice and warm
and nobody bugged us.
We were able to sleep through the night
and left in the morning, left
it clean and no harm, no foul.
- [Mark] That's great.
- So.
- [Mark] That's right, but I
talked to your wife last week
and you guys both seem like
a great couple. (chuckles)
- Yeah, we're like normal
people, we're just, yeah,
we're just homeless drug addicts,
kind of this little side thing.
It's like, oh, by the way,
we're homeless drug addicts.
- [Mark] Yeah, you both seem competent
and intelligent and...
- Yeah, capable, all of that.
Capable of having normal
lives, we just choose
to have this lifestyle for now.
- [Mark] What is, I mean...
- I don't know what it is.
- [Mark] What is it that
people don't understand
about addiction, drug addiction?
- I just, for me, I don't
really make any excuses for it.
I like getting high, and
with this type of drug,
getting high with this type of drug,
unfortunately, you have to keep it up.
You can't just use it and
then take some time off.
You have to stay at it, so
it's like an investment of time
and everything and,
but what it is is just,
for me, it's a choice.
I like getting high, I chose
to get high on that drug,
I choose to continue to
get high on that drug
and unless I take some
time and actually detox,
I know what it really takes
to get off of that drug.
I can't just snap my
fingers and get off of it.
It would take time and
setting some time aside
and having a place and the
ability to detox to do that.
I do it when I'm in jail.
That's pretty much a lot
of us, that's what we do.
We detox when we're--
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah, jail's
the way to get clean.
- Get clean when we're in
jail and then some of us say
we're gonna stay clean when
we get out, some of us don't,
but it's rare that we do.
- [Mark] But that's a
common way people get clean.
- Yeah, yeah.
Probably the only clean time
over the last four years
I've had was the time I was in jail.
- [Mark] Yeah, no, I mean,
it's, I think that the draw
that drugs like heroin
and crack have on people
is just so strong that...
- Yeah, it's really a commitment.
It's sort of just like
you almost accepted it.
It's like, sort of like,
okay, well, here we go again.
You know all of the shit
that comes along with it.
It's not even so much the doing the drug
and the drug itself.
It's all of the other stuff
that comes along with it,
the making money, having money,
who's gonna have the drug,
who's gonna buy the stuff
that I'm gonna steal
from the store to get the drug.
It's all of that other shit,
all those other relationships,
all that stuff that
becomes time-consuming.
It takes up all, everything,
it takes up your whole time,
your whole day, your whole night.
It becomes everything, becomes your life
and it becomes a lifestyle.
- [Mark] And then there's all
the stigma that goes with it.
- Right, and then there's
the judgment of people
and stuff like that and you
sort of just become this,
I don't even really
think about that so much
because, like you said,
when you first look at me,
when a lot of people look at me,
I'm able to keep my
image up and keep myself.
I can get cleaned up, I can
put on nice clothes, I can--
- [Mark] No, you could totally pass for...
- Cover it up.
- [Mark] Straight as an arrow.
- Exactly, so.
It's one of the things,
unlike crack or alcohol
or something like that,
heroin is one of the things
you can definitely keep
hidden if you choose to.
- [Mark] Is it, do you
think it's pretty common?
I asked your wife this.
Is it pretty common?
Outside of Skid Row, are there people
using heroin and fentanyl?
- Yeah, yeah, there's
a, the amount of people
that are downtown is a
small, very small percentage
of the actual drug users
that use that drug.
Most of them are out other
places, Hollywood, the Valley,
places like that, the Westside.
- [Mark] And they're
trying to function as?
- Yeah, just trying, yeah,
just still doing the deal.
Santa Monica has a huge, has
a big homeless population,
and Hollywood does, too.
There's a lot of people that
have just kind of dropped out.
- [Mark] But do people have
jobs and still use these drugs?
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
I've been a commodities
broker, I've done sales,
and there was a guy who
used to sit behind me
and he would nod out every day,
and see the fentanyl patches
stuck to his, (chuckles)
stuck to his chest,
and this was 2010, 2011,
something like that.
I didn't even use fentanyl
or even heard of it yet
at the time but people were
already starting to use it
back then, 10 years ago.
It's been about 10 years, it's
been popular about 10 years.
It's really gotten, people
starting to use it a lot more.
- [Mark] Excellent, well, Adam,
thank you so much for talking to me.
- Absolutely, no problem,
it's a pleasure, Mark.
- [Mark] Very, very interesting.
- All right, anytime.
- [Mark] And I wish you the best of luck.
- You want to continue it again sometime,
more than welcome to, so.
- [Mark] Yeah, maybe I'll
have you guys in together.
- Yeah, maybe we'll do
a couples thing, sure.
- [Mark] That'd be interesting.
- All right, thanks, Mark.
- [Mark] Cool, thank you.